a lot of people have
mistakenly
taken my kind interactions for weakness
if you're a vendor who thinks I'm weak
in negotiating and I at the last minute
buy all the product from someone else
instead of you you very quickly realized
you were mistaken and so people will
realize that through action who you are
I'm more fascinated by the person that
thinks
invoking fear into people or seemingly
not being kind is a good strategy when
they're incapable to execute with action
on the back end then you just become a
barking dog that everybody realizes will
never bite and then you become a doormat
and people walk all over you
and you've lost twice